teen titans go to the movies finally
sees televisions Teen Titans on the big
screen the film is a must-see for any DC
comic fans and is packed with Easter
eggs cameos and a surprise and credit
scene throughout this video I'll be
discussing that scene in particular so
there will be heavy spoilers and it may
be worth avoiding this video for now if
you want to remain unspoiled with that
out the way I'm definition and I ruin
the movie so you don't have too many
fans of the original Teen Titans show
were annoyed by the fact that the reboot
Teen Titans go simplified the designs of
their favorite characters so that they
appealed to children and a wider
audience the post credit scene addresses
this switch up when halfway through a
wealth of static hits the screen when
this clears the Titans are back in their
original incarnations and begin talking
to one another
hurry there's not much time say Starfire
as Raven addresses that the audience
needs to know that they are still alive
this is the Teen Titans can anyone hear
us
Robin asks as he turns the camera round
and pointer at the Titans saying we
think we may have found a way back this
follows up and confirms the room at that
Teen Titans may be returning for a sixth
season many fans felt disappointed that
the show was cancelled after its fifth
one and the Internet has been awash with
those in support of its return recently
Raven voice artist Tara Strong tweeted
that Warner Brothers were considering
bringing the show back and this post
credit scene pretty much confirms here
so are you excited to see the return of
the original Teen Titans and what
version of the team do you prefer
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
subscribe to my channel I create content
like this weekly and they'll definitely
be something on here that you love if
you're
film recently I discussed the plot of
the meg as well as the differences
between the film and the book so make
sure you check that video out next
thanks very much for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you